11 years ago, there's
something quite interesting,
because 11 years ago, we,
the College of Science,
decided to create
this lecture series,
because there was a court case
in Pennsylvania in which they
were trying to add intelligent
design to the curriculum
of the schools in Pennsylvania.
And it went up to the courts.
The courts decided that
intelligent design was not
science.
But we here decided
at that point,
even before that court
did what they had to do--
we decided that it was
really important that people,
that the public, that
all of us should really
understand the facts
that then we're
asked to give opinions about.
Reminds me of the
very famous saying
of Patrick Moynihan,
who says we're all
entitled to our facts--
sorry, we're all
entitled to our opinions,
but we're not
entitled to our facts.
[APPLAUSE]
So 11 years ago, we
started in the Center
for Creative Photography,
where there are 250 seats.
And clearly, there was
enormous interest in the topic.
And then, we just continued.
And interestingly
enough, 11 years since,
we're here, debating facts.
So I think more important
than ever, it is for all of us
to understand truly
what the facts are,
make our intelligent
opinions on the facts.
So more important than ever,
lecture series like these
are quite topical.
So this lecture series is funded
by great folks in the community
that I think we
should all appreciate.
Tucson Electric Power.
Let me just say them
all, and then we
can give an applause
to all of them.
Ventana Medical Systems,
the Arizona Daily Star,
Cox Communication,
Galileo Circle.
And if any of you want a good
seat, join the Galileo Circle
and also support the community
through your efforts.
Godat Design,
Holualoa Companies,
the Marshall Foundation,
Nguyen and Tarbet Patent Law,
Raytheon, Research Corporation
for Science Advancement,
and Vantage West Credit Union.
How about if we just give them
all a big round of applause?
[APPLAUSE]
So for 10 years, we've
been pushing the envelope
of describing interesting facts
that we now know as scientists,
which in fact are
central to the debate
that we are in in the
policy and political arena.
Last year was about global
climate change, for example.
We've talked about the genome.
All of you have had some
skirmish with one or the other.
And we can go on and on.
Facts are important.
And that's what this
lecture series is all about.
So now, we're really
getting into--
and by the way, the title
of "Rethinking Reality"
was before the election.
So it has nothing
to do with politics.
It has to do with physics.
But you can make your own
opinion about the facts.
And today, we're going to
talk about how physics,
since the inception of physics,
has been trying to understand
the universe that
we live in and how,
as we move farther and farther
away from what we really
observe, what we're
evolutionary-wise
capable of accepting,
coming to the opinion
or coming to the conclusion
that the universe is incredibly
weird.
So today, Keith Dienes
is going to give us
a presentation that
will try to set up
the lectures for the
rest of the time.
We're going to have five
of these lectures about how
physics behaves at very high
pressures and temperatures,
what the quantum
world is all about,
what the very small world of
particle physics is all about.
All of that is what I hope we
will all learn about today.
So Keith received his bachelor's
from Princeton, his master's
and PhD from Cornell,
came here to the U of A,
after he held post-doc
positions at McGill University
in Montreal, at the
Institute for Advanced
Study in Princeton,
and at CERN in Geneva.
This is typical of
our faculty members
here in the College of Science.
Most recently, Keith has been
engaged in public service.
And he's a program director
for the Theoretical High-Energy
Physics and Cosmology at the
National Science Foundation
in Washington DC, where he
oversees the funding of fields
across the entire US and helps
to develop federal science
policy in these fields.
Keith's primary interests are
in theoretical high-energy
physics.
He focuses on new
ideas for physics
beyond the so-called standard
model of particle physics.
These ideas include
supersymmetry,
grand unification, large extra
dimensions, and ultimately,
string theory.
Most recently, he has been
developing a new approach
to the dark matter problem.
You'll hear throughout
this lecture series
that astronomers and
astrophysicists have decided
that most of the
universe is made out
of dark matter and dark energy.
So there's no poetry in it,
but that's what they know.
And he's working on that.
His results have been featured
in Scientific American, The New
Scientist, Science
Magazine, and Physics Today.
And he's a fellow of the
American Physical Society.
Please help me
welcome Keith Dienes.
[APPLAUSE]
Well, it's a
pleasure to be here.
I'm really happy to
see a large audience.
I won't say it's the
largest ever existed, maybe.
But it certainly is gratifying
to see so many people
interested in science.
And that's what's
great, I think.
So this year, the University
of Arizona College
of Science Lecture
Series will be
focusing on some
extraordinarily big questions.
And you see them here.
What are the fundamental
building blocks
of the physical world?
What are the different kinds of
glue that hold these building
blocks together?
What happens at the extremes
of matter and energy, space
and time?
What are the laws that govern
the behavior of all things,
large and small,
seen and unseen?
Where do these laws come from?
And what do they tell us
about the birth and death
of the universe and
everything in between?
So through the upcoming
weeks, four physicists
will be here, in addition
to me, to tell you
about their cutting-edge
research that
pushes the frontiers in
attempting to understand
and answer these questions.
But we had
organizational meetings
to plan this lecture series.
And as we were talking, we felt
that something was lacking.
Most people, we thought,
really have a general idea
of what chemistry is
or what biology is.
But what exactly is physics?
How is physics different
from the other sciences?
What are the big
ideas in physics?
Is there a corresponding
big picture
that physicists carry
around in their heads
when they think about
the natural world?
So that's really going to be the
goal of this kickoff lecture.
Rather than tell you about my
own research, which I will not
do, I'll instead aim to
provide a leisurely tour
through some of the most
cutting-edge concepts
in modern physics.
And taken together,
all these ideas
are shaping the big picture
that physicists have ultimately
formed about the universe
and the laws that govern it.
And this is, ultimately, part
of how physicists are currently
rethinking the rules of reality.
So this won't be physics 101.
The ideas won't be elementary.
Rather, this will be physics
500, really the cutting edge
concepts, but all
explained, hopefully,
at a very non-technical level.
So that's the goal.
Now, the title of my
slide is "Rethinking
the Rules of Reality."
And this is, if you think about
it, a rather strange title.
It has three components--
rules, rethinking, and reality.
And in this lecture,
what I'd like to do
is discuss each
of these in turn.
But first, we should start
with what physics is.
What is physics?
If you go up to the street and
ask a random person walking
around to name the most
intelligent person who ever
lived, you might get--
and people do this, often
on late night talk shows.
You might get a
lot of responses--
Shakespeare or Bach or Mozart
or Beethoven or maybe Charles
Darwin.
But far and away, the number
one answer is a physicist.
And you all know who he is.
So if you start to narrow the
question down-- say, well,
amongst living
people, who is it?
The number one answer,
again, is another physicist.
This is Stephen Hawking,
a British cosmologist.
If Hollywood wants to portray
smart people, what do they do?
Again, they make them into
physicists, plus an engineer
without a PhD, but he's
allowed to hang around also.
If you ask people, what are
the most famous equations
in all of science?
Well, they also are equations
that come from physics,
E equals mc squared
and F equals ma.
What is the reason for this
fascination with physics?
Ultimately, I think it's
because physics is different.
Physicists tend
to view the world
in strange, abstract ways.
And I want to give
you some examples
of what I mean by this.
If you study how the
gravitational attraction
of the sun causes
the planets to move
in stable elliptical
orbits around it,
you're likely to
be an astronomer.
And astronomers have done
this for many, many years.
If you study how the
massive forces involved
in tectonic shift
cause mountains
to rise and the
earthquakes to occur,
you're likely to be a geologist.
If you study how an organism
swims through a fluid using
its flagella, or how a
hummingbird beats its wings so
as to remain stationary
above a flower,
you're likely to be a biologist.
If you study how the
electric fields involved
in forming chemical bonds
prevent the individual atoms
in a molecule from moving
around freely, thereby
forming a stable crystal,
you're likely to be a chemist
or a material scientist.
But a physicist?
Well, a physicist looks at all
of those situations and says,
well, in each case,
there is a force
being applied to an object.
And that force results
in a certain change
in the motion of that object,
either creating motion
or maintaining equilibrium.
Let's just study the notion of
force as an abstract entity.
And let's also just study
motion and equilibrium
as abstract entities.
We don't need to
specify whether we're
talking about planets or
continents or hummingbirds
or chemical bonds.
And now we can ask
the general questions.
How is force related to motion?
When do forces
produce equilibrium?
When don't they?
Note that we're seeking
universal truths,
abstract truths, statements
about how the universe operates
at all times, in all places,
in all circumstances.
These are the physical laws
that we seek to uncover,
the physical laws that
underpin all things.
And we're seeking to
understand their consequences.
This is physics.
Now, I've said physical laws.
But, in fact, these physical
laws are nothing but the rules
that we're talking
about, the rules
that govern the natural
world as we know it.
So let me give you an example.
You've all heard this
equation, F equals ma.
It's the discovery of Newton.
It's his so-called second law.
What it means is that
forces acting on objects
cause them to accelerate.
Now, it turns out
that this is true,
no matter what the object is, no
matter what produces the force.
Now, this law may seem obvious.
But for 2,000 years, humanity
was confused about this
and actually believed
something different.
What was believed
was that forces
were necessary to induce
and sustain motion.
That's wrong.
Instead, we now
know, since Newton,
that forces are only
necessary to change motion,
not to cause it or sustain
it, but to change it,
to produce acceleration.
It's the job of physicists
to propose such laws
and to test them in a
variety of circumstances.
Ultimately, through repeated
experimental conformation,
we come to believe in
the validity of a law
as a universal truth of nature.
I'll give you another
Newton-based example.
This one is a little
more interesting.
We just saw the apple fall
through from the tree,
to the Earth from
the top of the tree.
It's the usual, well-known
story that Newton
sat under the apple
tree, and the apple
fell and hit him on the head.
And he then, according
to the story,
realized that this is the result
of the same force, gravity,
that's responsible for the
moon orbiting the Earth.
But you've heard this
story, but you may
have thought, how can that be?
The moon never crashes into
the Earth like the apple.
These appear to be
different phenomena.
What Newton realized in that
moment is that they're not.
In each case, gravity
does the same thing.
It pulls an object
directly towards the center
of the Earth.
Now, for the apple, that was
the only motion there was.
So that's all that
occurred, and the apple just
fell directly to the Earth.
For the moon, however, there
was another tangential velocity
already existing.
The moon was already
moving parallel
to the Earth's
surface, tangentially
toward the horizon.
So the combination of falling
and that tangential velocity
together traced out
that curved orbit.
But in each case, the
gravity part was universal.
And it does only one thing,
pulls toward the center.
The commonality and
universality of physical law,
the idea that the same
principles might underlie
different phenomena,
is not always obvious,
as we see from this example.
As in the case of the falling
apple versus the stable lunar
orbit, the phenomena themselves
might look very different.
And they might have vastly
different implications.
Now, if we were content to
understand each phenomenon
separately on its own
terms, which is fine,
but we might then miss the
deeper common structure.
It's the job of the physicist
to probe more deeply
and uncover and discover the
commonalities that underlie
the workings of the universe
at their deepest and most
abstract levels.
Now, all good science,
really, starts
with observation and
then classification,
based on similarities
and differences.
However, physicists aim
to do something further,
to extract underlying
principles,
the underlying physical
laws, the rules that we've
been talking about, even
if they look different
in different contexts, as in
the apple case with the moon.
And then, to use these
physical laws in order
to predict phenomena,
which are not
yet seen, perhaps with energies
or sizes or temperatures which
have never been probed before,
or new settings which have
never been explored before.
Sometimes, the laws of
physics, as we formulated them,
then work well in these new
contexts, and we say, great.
We believe in it even more.
However, sometimes
they don't work well
in these new contexts.
And they then
require reformulation
into new, more general laws,
whose scope of validity
is even larger than
they were before.
Thus, laws are not abandoned.
We don't just say, oh,
we thought it was true,
but now it's completely
false, and we throw it away.
Instead, laws are
constantly incorporated
into bigger, more
complete structures,
more complete structures.
And this is how
our field advances.
Now, as with any branch of
science, input from experiment
is critical.
Scientific progress,
especially in physics,
is a dialogue between
experiment and theory.
Experimentalists communicate
directly with nature.
They're the ones who actually
talk to nature directly,
because they take
direct measurements.
Nature talks to them.
It's a special, special role,
really, for experimentalists.
And they do this by building
sophisticated experiments
in the cleverest ways,
in order to extract data.
By contrast, theorists
then take this data
and interpret it in terms
of the physical laws
and the fundamental
principles they've developed.
If necessary, they
hypothesize extensions
of these laws and principles.
They then propose new
ideas and predictions,
which experimentalists
then proceed to test.
Thus, the field really
walks on two legs,
shifting back and forth between
experimentalists and theorists.
Now, many fields of
study have people
who tend to be more involved in
a laboratory setting and people
who tend to be maybe more
running numerical simulations
or working on blackboards.
But physics tends to be one
of the most extreme in having
a dichotomy between
experimentalists and theorists,
to the extent that almost
no functioning physicist
today does both.
And it's a shame.
But we need such
specialized training
that very early on,
when you're growing up
and you're a would-be physicist,
you know, in your heart,
you're either going to be an
experimentalist or a theorist.
Most of us choose when
we're undergrads or maybe
graduate students.
I was in charge of our
graduate program admissions
here for a long time at the U
of A in the physics department.
And one of the first
things you look
at when you're opening a
folder for an applicant
is, is this going to
be an experimentalist?
Or is this going
to be a theorist?
Because this is right away
the first, most important
question that you want
to know about the person.
It identifies them.
Now, I've been talking
about understanding
the fundamental laws.
But that's not all.
As you know from, for
example, playing chess,
you can know the rules that
govern how each piece moves,
and still you have no
idea how to play the game,
have no concept of the
grand strategies that
will result in victory.
There's more to actually
playing a game than knowing
these fundamental rules.
And similarly, in
parallel with the process
of discovering new physical
law, physicists also
have to do something else.
They work hard to use these
laws with increasing power
and sophistication, in order
to understand and predict
phenomena of ever
increasing complexity
across the entire
spectrum of science,
everything from material science
and chemistry and biology,
all the way to astrophysics
or nuclear science or quantum
science or engineering
or complexity theory.
In each case, what one finds is
that new emergent phenomena can
appear that might not have
been anticipated based
on the fundamental laws alone.
Having more elements in
your system, having more
produces different behavior.
More leads to different.
Physicists, nevertheless,
study all these behaviors
from their uniquely
abstract perspective.
Thus, I think it's
fair to say, physics
sits at the foundation
of most sciences
that deal with
the natural world.
Now, historically,
physics has gone
through many major upheavals,
in which a set of laws
were recognized
not to be complete,
and were slowly
and painstakingly
understood to be mere special
cases of more general laws.
This has caused physicists
to continually rethink
the very nature of the rules
that govern the universe.
This is the rethinking part.
Now, we don't do this randomly.
In general, as we grope to
develop new, more sophisticated
rules, we're guided by a
number of profound concepts
that seem to underlie
almost everything we
know about the natural world.
One important guide that
physicists use is symmetry.
And I'm sure you all
have an idea of symmetry.
Symmetry is everywhere
in the natural world.
There are many different
kinds of symmetry.
Here's a left/right
reflection symmetry.
The left side and the
right side are the same.
If you just put this
picture in a mirror image,
it would look identical.
There are other kinds of
symmetries-- rotational
symmetries, 3-fold symmetries,
4-fold, the cloverleaf,
5-fold, as in the jellyfish,
6-fold, as in the tapestry,
9-fold.
That is an aerial view of
a Bahá'í temple in India.
10-fold, that is a diamond.
There are other
kinds of symmetries,
for example, lattice
symmetries, where,
again, if you know
a fundamental cell,
it fills out the whole
plane in the same way.
There can be
cylindrical symmetries,
where you have a
symmetry about rotating
around a central vertical
axis, as in the tin can
or in the vase.
Finally, you can even have
the spherical symmetry.
Here's an example of a sphere.
Now, you can ask, why are
symmetries so important?
Why does nature care
about symmetries?
Well, there's one, I think,
very profound reason.
Symmetry produces pizza.
No, symmetries are
important because, I think,
they allow us to describe
a lot of information
about an entire
object using only
a little bit of information.
For example, if an object
has a left/right symmetry,
then if I tell
you everything you
need to know about
the left side,
you already know the right side.
It's very efficient.
If an object has a rotational
symmetry, like the pizza,
then if I tell you
what's happening
in one slice or one
wedge, you already
know what the whole
thing is like.
In the case of a lattice,
you know the entire picture
just by describing
one central cell.
So nature, I think,
loves symmetries
because of the efficiencies
they encapsulate.
However, as we'll
see, physicists also
love symmetries, because
they simplify the situation,
and they enable us
to solve problems
that might be too complex
to solve in other ways.
Now, there's another
idea that guides
physicists when we're
looking to understand
how to rethink things.
And that has to do
with conservation laws.
The basic idea is that
in certain situations,
a physical quantity,
some number,
some quantity that
we use to describe
the system is conserved.
And what that means is that even
though the system may evolve,
and its characteristics may
change as a function of time,
certain quantities that
describe the system
are nevertheless the same or
fixed at all moments in time.
And perhaps the easiest
example, the one
you're most familiar with,
is conservation of energy.
For example,
consider a pendulum.
What's happening is that the
height that exists at the edges
is, by the time you come
to the middle, traded.
You lose height.
And instead, you gain speed.
So height is traded for
speed, and back and forth.
Something is conserved,
because we don't
have height when we have speed.
It's traded back and forth.
What's conserved is the
total energy of the system.
The ideas of symmetries
and conservation laws
are very old ones in physics.
They go back to Newton.
But remarkably, it wasn't
until the early 20th century
that a connection was actually
found between symmetries
and conservation laws.
In my opinion, this connection
represents possibly the most
profound discovery in all of
theoretical and mathematical
physics.
And it states nothing more than
if a physical system exhibits
a continuous symmetry, then
a corresponding quantity
must always be conserved.
In other words,
for each symmetry,
there is a corresponding
conserved quantity,
and vice versa, a
corresponding conservation law.
So two of the deepest concepts
in theoretical physics,
symmetries and
conservation laws,
are actually fused into one.
I'll give you an
example of this.
Here we have an experiment
that we are preparing to do,
maybe at 8:20 in the morning.
Most scientists are not in
the office at 8:20 in the--
let's make this PM.
And they do the experiment.
And they drop the thing
in, and it turns yellow.
And they say, aha.
OK.
Now, they may repeat the
experiment later at 10:10,
and again, drop it in.
They should get
the same results,
because the laws of
physics should not
care whether the
experiment was done
at 8 o'clock or 10 o'clock.
In other words, if the laws have
this property that it doesn't
matter when you
do the experiment,
then this connection I
was telling you about
says that there is a
conserved quantity.
And the conserved
quantity is energy.
And this system must
conserve energy.
So somehow, time is
connecting to energy.
Completely mysterious, but this
is what this theorem tells us.
Now, this connection between
symmetries and conserved
quantities really does represent
a fundamental observation
and theorem.
It's actually a theorem,
proven mathematically,
about how nature works at the
deepest, most abstract level.
And as you might imagine, the
ramifications of a theorem
like this reach to any physical
system that can be imagined,
determining what processes
may occur and which ones not.
The ones that conserve the
conserved quantity would,
and the ones that don't conserve
the conserved quantity cannot
occur, because they would be
violating the conservation law.
Although this theorem
was originally
formulated in classical
Newtonian mechanics,
it extends readily to
relativistic situations
and even quantum mechanics.
Its implications extend
across all of physics,
from subatomic physics
to entire galaxies
and everything in between.
In fact, I'm not
the only one who
thinks this is an amazing
result in theoretical physics.
Two physicists
who recently wrote
this book have said,
this is "certainly
one of the most important
mathematical theorems ever
proved in guiding the
development of modern physics,
possibly on a par with
the Pythagorean theorem,"
which is about the
sides of triangles,
proved by the Ancient Greeks.
We're saying for
2,000 years, this
might be the most
important result.
So you might wonder who
is the physicist who
actually discovered this?
Why haven't you
heard of this person?
Well, this is her name.
She's Emmy Noether.
She was born in Erlangen,
Germany in 1882.
She studied
mathematics, but only
by special permission,
because it wasn't permitted
for women in those
days in Germany
to study subjects
such as mathematics.
So she had to get
special permission.
But she did and got her PhD
from the University of Erlangen.
They were happy to keep her,
working in their research
facilities, but
without pay, of course,
for the next seven years, before
she moved to the University
of Göttingen, also in Germany,
where she spent the next four
years lecturing under the
name of male colleagues.
They felt that,
well, she couldn't
teach a course by herself.
So she had pretend that she's
substituting for somebody else.
Again, this was the prejudice
against female physicists
at the time.
But she did this.
And her fame was
readily apparent.
And she had loads
of students who
wanted to follow
her around campus,
taking whatever courses
she was teaching.
Her fame grew in both
mathematics and physics,
ultimately culminating
in her plenary lecture
to the International Conference
of Mathematicians in 1932
in Zurich.
This is a big deal.
But when the Nazis dismissed
Jews from faculty positions
in Germany, she had to escape.
And so she moved to Bryn
Mawr College in the US
and died two years later
in 1935 of complications
from surgery for
an ovarian cyst.
So died in midlife.
It's a wonder what
she might have
done if she had lived longer.
When she died,
The New York Times
would not publish a eulogy.
But Albert Einstein felt
compelled to at least write
a letter, a tribute.
And he wrote that "in the
judgment of the most competent
living mathematicians,
Fraeulein Noether
was the most significant
creative mathematical genius
thus far produced since the
higher education of women
began."
That's high praise, coming
from Albert Einstein, no less.
So using ideas
like these, physics
has advanced through
many different conceptual
revolutions.
Each one called for
a radical rethinking
of the fundamental
rules of the game.
So what I'd like to do now,
in the next part of the talk,
is just take a quick,
brief tour through some
of these conceptual
revolutions in physics.
My list is not complete.
I'm sure other people would have
put different items on the list
and taken off from the list.
But this gives you
a sense of the kind
of rethinking that
we're constantly
having to do as physicists.
So, of course, our
field, like many things,
starts with the ancient Greeks.
In some sense, they
were important,
because they were
the first to ask
the same kinds of questions,
the fundamental questions
that we ask.
But our field really got going
with the Newtonian revolution
in the late 1600s.
This is the modern
birth of our field.
What it did was it established
a clear mathematical set
of principia,
principles, upon which
the entire structure of the
universe was supposed to rest.
Another big breakthrough-- here,
I'll attribute this to Maxwell.
Maxwell was a
British mathematician
and British physicist
in the mid-1800s.
He worked on
electromagnetic theory
and fused electric
and magnetic phenomena
into a single framework, which
we now call electromagnetism.
Before him, people believed
that electric fields
and magnetic fields were
distinct, separate things.
But what we've learned now
is that if an electric field
varies in space-- it's different
in different places in space
or different in time,
and it fluctuates--
then that immediately pops into
existence a magnetic field.
And likewise, if a
magnetic field varies,
that pops into existence
an electric field.
Together, they're unified to
produce electromagnetic waves.
This was his big discovery.
And not only that, the
electromagnetic waves
move at the speed of light.
So somehow, now, there's
a deep connection
between electromagnetism and
light, which hadn't really
been understood before, but
now it becomes apparent.
Another great development was
the atomic principle, the idea
that matter is discrete.
Before this
realization, matter was
considered to be a dense,
continuous, pudding-like
substance.
No matter how much you
zoomed in and looked
at little pieces of it
and broke them apart
and looked at further
little pieces of it,
it always appeared to
be a continuous pudding.
This is what people
believed would be the case.
But we actually know now
that matter is ultimately
made of discrete atoms, and
each atom is mostly empty space.
That's kind of strange.
Another major
development had to do
with what I'll call statistical
mechanics and thermodynamics.
This is also the late 1800s.
This is Newtonian
physics applied
to the realm of the very
many, the very many particles.
And when you have
very many particles,
they can have a temperature.
And what was
believed at the time
was that-- well,
people knew about heat.
But they didn't know that
heat was a form of energy,
that it can be
traded back and forth
for other kinds of energy,
like kinetic energy
or potential energy.
But this was the discovery that
heat is another form of energy.
That enabled the development
of the laws of thermodynamics
and the recognition
that systems tend
to evolve in the direction
of increasing disorder.
And I'm sure many of you are
familiar with this phenomenon.
Your desk never happens
to get neater by itself.
Things evolve in the direction
of increasing disorder.
You'll be happy to know
this is a law of physics.
And you can use
that as an excuse
any time somebody says, why are
things always getting messier?
But it's true.
If you see a glass
of milk fall off
a table, shatter on the
floor, and the milk goes
flying in all the
different directions,
and you run the
movie backwards, you
would find that the
milk would collect,
and the glass would
pop up onto the table.
You know which way is
the correct direction
of time for the movie.
But the reason is
because of these results.
This sets a preferred
direction for the flow of time.
The physicist who
really pioneered this
was named Boltzmann.
And he was very
concerned about this.
He had developed this
result that there
was a preferred direction.
But in order to
develop these results,
he used Newtonian equations.
Newtonian physics
has the property
that if you take
time to minus time,
if you run the movie
forward or backward,
it doesn't make a difference.
If two billiard balls
collide that way,
that's the same thing as
if they collide that way.
Newtonian physics doesn't
really seem to care.
And yet, he somehow, when
considering lots of particles,
found that systems
tend to evolve
in the direction of
increasing disorder.
He was giving public
lectures on this.
This was his major lifework, his
biggest result in his career.
And one day, somebody asked him
from the back of the audience,
but wait a minute.
You started with
equations that had
this property that you could run
the movie forward or backward.
And now you're claiming
there's a result that there's
a preferred direction.
How can that be?
He didn't know the answer.
He worried about
this for a long time.
Eventually, this
drove him to suicide,
which is not a good example
of work-life balance,
and also the reason
why, perhaps, I'm
glad there won't be a question
and answer session after this.
Another revolution that
happened rather quickly
was special relativity.
This is Newtonian
physics extended
to the realm of the very fast.
And here, what you found
were remarkable things.
No matter how long or hard
you push on an object,
you can never make it go
faster than the speed of light.
That's not expected.
People moving with
different velocities
seem to see the same objects
as having different sizes.
So if I'm looking
at a house, and I
see it has a certain size, but
somebody on a train moving by,
looking at the same
house, would say
it has a different
size than I see.
Speed distorts reality.
But this is also what
special relativity tells us.
Another major intellectual
rethinking that had to occur
has to do with
general relativity.
This was 1916.
This is Einstein, as
well as the previous one.
This is Newtonian physics
extended to the realm
of the very massive.
Gravity, it turns out, is
nothing but the bending
of space and time.
Now, that's weird enough.
I'm not even going to
try to explain that.
Subsequent lectures by Sam
Gralla and Feryal Özel will
talk about this.
But this is the
foundation of all
of modern cosmology, the Big
Bang, the expanding universe,
black holes, event
horizons, gravity waves.
It all comes from here.
The quantum revolution
is another one
I'm sure you've heard of.
This developed slowly
over many years.
But it finally reached its
crescendo in the mid-1920s.
This is Newtonian
physics extended
to the realm of the subatomic.
And the basic idea
is about matter.
Is it a particle?
Or is it a wave?
Sometimes, it behaves
like a particle.
like a wave, when
you go to the subatomic world.
In particular, one
weird thing one finds
is that identical
experiments will
follow the same laws of
physics, but need not
produce the same outcomes.
You can have an experiment
here and an experiment there.
They're identical.
And they follow both the
same laws of physics.
And yet, this one says A at
the end, and this one says B.
In fact, all that can be
predicted, it turns out,
are the probabilities
that you'll
get A or get B as
the end results.
Absolute determinism was lost
from physics at this moment.
You'll hear more about
this quantum weirdness
in the lecture by Pierre Meystre
at the end of this lecture
series.
But this is what he'll
be talking about.
Another major revolution has to
do with quantum field theory.
This is quantum mechanics
joined with special relativity.
And what we learn from here,
through all these kinds
of weird diagrams that you
often see people draw--
physicists often are playing
with diagrams like that--
is the discovery of anti-matter.
For every particle, there's
a corresponding anti-particle
that it can annihilate with.
And in some sense, this is
finally the dream of alchemy.
This is modern alchemy.
One particle can be annihilated.
And a completely different
particle, a different element
can be created in its place.
The vacuum, which is just
another word for empty space,
can create
particle/anti-particle pairs
out of nothing.
This, again, was a
very strange concept.
Now, such revolutions
have continued even
to the present day, causing
a continual rethinking
of the ultimate
nature of reality.
I could have
continued that story
with things that happened in
the '70s and '80s and '90s,
and I will.
But I want to put this in
the last part of the talk
here, because what we're
interested now to understand
is then, well, if
we're continually
rethinking the ultimate nature
of reality, where are we now?
In particular, what describes
the reality of the universe
as we understand it today?
So now, I want to switch
gears a little bit
and tell you the
big picture we think
we have today about the
nature of the physical world.
What are the fundamental things?
Well, when I ask a question
like "what is fundamental?",
I really am asking
for two things.
I'm asking for what are the
fundamental particles that
make up the matter that
everything is made of?
And what are the
fundamental forces
that describe the interactions
between the different particles
of matter?
But even the use of
the word "fundamental"
is a bit strange
and time-dependent.
If you think about biology
for a minute, you might say,
well, the fundamental object
in biology is the cell.
And for a long time,
people thought that.
But then we came to understand
that maybe the nucleus had
a very special role to play.
And maybe within the
nucleus, we discovered DNA
and began to think that
maybe that was fundamental.
Chemistry, similarly, one
might have thought compounds,
but then actually molecules
and maybe individual atoms
and the atomic structure.
For physics, what is the
corresponding analogy?
What are the different things
that are fundamental to us?
Well, it turns out that what's
fundamental to a physicist
depends on the energy
scale with which you probe,
with which you look.
If you look with
more energy, you
might see smaller and
smaller distances.
Why?
Because in general,
it takes more energy
to probe smaller and
smaller distances.
So if you're looking with
more and more energy,
you might see different
fundamental things.
So the energy units we're
going to use to tell this story
are called eV And
this is just a code.
It stands for something
called electron volt.
But basically, all
you need to think of
is that this is
the natural energy
scale associated with atoms.
OK.
So the fundamental particles
at different energy scales--
well, at the eV scale,
the electron volt scale,
the fundamental
elements are atoms,
in particular nuclei
plus electrons
that orbit around them.
But it turns out, as you know,
that there are different types
of nuclei that exist.
These fill out the different
elements, the periodic table.
And if you go into any
chemistry classroom,
or maybe you remember
from your own chemistry
experience in your own
high school classroom,
you saw the periodic table.
And it was arranged in certain
rows and certain columns,
because there were certain
repeating structures that made
sense to arrange it this way.
There was a structure to it.
That structure, this
repeating pattern
suggested that there
was a deeper structure.
And indeed, there is one.
To probe this, we go to higher
energies, megaelectron-volts.
This is a million
times stronger.
And at this level, we see
that a nucleus is actually
a collection of
protons and neutrons.
And so those
different arrangements
of protons and neutrons, with
different numbers of protons
and numbers of
neutrons, that's what
makes the different elements and
fills out the periodic table.
OK.
So at the MeV, the
megaelectron-volts scale,
we would say, well, the
elementary particles
are protons and neutrons,
plus those electrons that
are orbiting.
And you might think
that for a while,
but it turns out that there
are many different types
of neutrons and protons.
These are collectively
called hadrons.
And you don't just have
proton and neutron,
but you also have pion and
kaon and rho meson and omega--
lots of Greek names.
This was all discovered
around the 1940s, '50s, '60s.
People were discovering
these like mad, couldn't even
keep up with the naming scheme.
And people said, well,
once again, there seems
to be a repeating structure.
Maybe there's something deeper.
And we looked with higher
energy machines, colliders
usually, at the
gigaelectron-volt scale, GeV.
And we found that inside
each proton were two up
quarks and a down quark.
And inside each neutron were
two down quarks and an up quark.
And so now, at the
gigaelectron-volt volt scale,
the fundamental particles
appear to be quarks,
plus those electrons again.
But once again, these
powerful colliders
found that that wasn't it.
There were many different
types of quarks,
not just up and down, but also--
and we had to give more names.
So here they come, strange
and charm and bottom and top.
You could feel the desperation.
Likewise, it turns out that
those electrons also were just
the beginning of a
series of particles
that were all very light.
They're called leptons.
"Lepto" is a Greek prefix.
It means "light."
And so these are
light particles.
So there was not
only the electron,
but a slightly heavier
one called the muon,
and a slightly heavier version
of that called the tau,
and then three different
other light particles, which
are called neutrinos.
And they're listed here
as neu sub-e, neu sub-mu,
and neu sub-tau--
electron neutrino, muon
neutrino, and tau neutrino.
They seem to go with the
other leptons, the electron,
the muon, and the tau.
For the remainder
of this talk, I just
want you to note that
there are three neutrinos,
and they come in
different tapes--
electron, muon,
and tau neutrinos.
So again, you suspect there
must be a deeper structure.
So of course, you're
dying to know what it is.
And if we had built the
superconducting supercollider
that you might
remember that people
used to talk about building
in Texas, about 20 years ago--
if that had been built, I
could probably tell you now.
But it was canceled,
and so we don't know.
So this is as far as
we've come so far.
And we wrap up our
knowledge in what
we call the standard model.
And the standard model--
here it is, very simple.
It consists of the particles
that we just saw, the quarks--
up, down, strange,
charm, top, bottom--
and the leptons--
electron and its neutrino,
muon and its neutrino,
tau and its neutrino.
These are grouped in packages
of three generations.
Each row is like a generation.
And we say that there are
three generations of quarks
and three generations
of leptons.
That's the particles.
And along with this
are the forces.
And there are many forces.
There are three fundamental
forces, it turns out.
Three primary forces.
And they each have
different strengths,
which are listed there,
in relative numbers.
The strongest one, with a
strength as big as one eighth,
that's called the strong force.
Its job is to prevent the
atomic nuclei from exploding
due to electrostatic repulsion.
Think about this for a minute.
You learned in
chemistry, when you
learned about the
atomic nucleus,
that it's made of
protons and neutrons.
Well, here's a question you
could have asked your teacher.
And probably, your teacher
wouldn't have known the answer.
But here's the question.
If the neutrons are
electrically neutral,
and the protons are
all positively charged,
then really you're shoving
all these positively
charged objects together.
But we know that
like charges repel.
So this thing would
want to go flying apart.
What, then, keeps an
atomic nucleus together?
The answer is that you're right.
The electromagnetism wants to
make the nucleus fly apart.
But there's another force,
which is even stronger.
It's this strong force,
which is attractive and holds
it together.
Then, there are two other
forces, the weak force
and the hypercharge force.
And as you see from the
relative strengths there,
they're much weaker.
These two forces
work always together.
They're very coupled in a
certain mathematical way.
And the best way to
describe what they do is--
the best way you know that
they're there, especially
in Arizona here--
they make the sun shine.
So we in Arizona owe our
uniqueness to these forces.
Now, you might say, but
what about electromagnetism?
None of those forces that I
listed are electromagnetism.
Well, it turns out that the weak
force and the hypercharge force
are like blue paint
and yellow paint.
But if you mix them together,
you get green paint.
Electromagnetism is
like that green paint.
It's not a primary color.
It's not a primary force.
The primary forces are
weak and hypercharge.
But they can be mixed
together, and that's
what electromagnetism is.
It's just a mixture of these
two more primary forces.
And the thing that
does the mixing
is that magic Higgs particle
that you've heard about.
So if you want, there's
a certain grammar
to the standard model.
The particles are the nouns,
the things that get acted on.
The forces are the verbs, the
things that do the acting.
And the Higgs modifies those
verbs and how they behave.
It's an adverb.
And if you want, you can
imagine the standard model
as having those three forces.
And you can imagine
listing them on an axis,
according to their strengths.
We'll List the strongest ones at
the bottom and the weakest ones
at the top.
So there's the strong at the
bottom and then the other two
further up.
Now, you might ask,
is that all there is?
But there's lots of reasons to
believe in something deeper.
The standard model has many
parameters you have to put in.
You have to say,
what is the mass
of every one of those quarks
and every one of those leptons?
You just have to measure
the number from data
and put it into your theory.
We would have liked to
predict something like that,
not just measure it from data.
So that's a bit mysterious.
There are also
conceptual questions
in the standard model.
Why do the particles come in
three generations like that?
Why are there are
three kinds of forces?
Why do these forces have
those different strengths?
Again, you would have hoped
a fundamental theory would
explain that, but we don't
have that explanation.
We just measured it, and those
numbers are what they are.
And that's not
really very pretty
from a physics
point of view, where
you want to understand
fundamental reasons for things.
And then, finally, there is
another force you know about,
gravity, which we haven't
even mentioned here.
How do you incorporate
the gravitational force?
How do you quantize gravity
and put it into this framework?
So once again, we
think there should
be-- we suspect that there
is a deeper structure.
So to go beyond
the standard model,
we have to build
big accelerators.
And fortunately, after 20
years of planning and building,
the next generation
of accelerators
and colliders and detectors
are yielding data now.
And what I'm showing
here is an overview
of the Geneva countryside.
This is just outside
Geneva, Switzerland.
In fact, right here behind
me, this white stretch
here is the runway of
the Geneva airport.
So you get a scale here.
These are many different towns.
Before I came to
the U of A, I worked
at this European Laboratory for
Particle Physics, which is just
outside Geneva, Switzerland.
And you would know
every day, as you
drove in and out, inside the
ring and outside the ring--
of course, the ring
here is all underground.
And we, underground, accelerate
particles and make collisions
and then look at
the debris and try
to figure out what the next
level of nature might be.
I mentioned that when
we do these collisions,
we have to have detectors to
see the spray of particles
that come out and measure them.
And one of the big detectors
is called the ATLAS detector.
I mention it because
our research group here
at the U of A was very
instrumental in building
that ATLAS detector and
effecting its overall design.
So you'll hear more about
this in the subsequent lecture
from Elliott Cheu.
But what kinds of
physics do we expect
to find at these colliders?
Well, this is now
speculation, but this
is what most people believe.
So this is part of
our big picture.
One idea is something
called supersymmetry,
often called SUSY.
And this is a new kind
of symmetry in physics.
And basically, what
it says is that
for every one of the
standard particles
that you saw before on the
left, the ones that make up
the standard model, there's a
corresponding supersymmetric
partner.
And that's a lot
of new particles.
But the reason we
imagine this is
because it would help to
solve a lot of puzzles.
It would help to explain
the relative strengths
of the forces, why
the strong force is so
much stronger than the weak
force, and so forth, like that.
It would help to explain why the
Higgs particle turns out to be
much lighter than we expected.
And it could even possibly
explain dark matter.
So supersymmetry is
one theory we really
believe that we will find.
And we actually
believe that we'll
find it at an energy
scale just slightly
higher than the standard model,
just a little bit higher up.
So this horizontal
axis that I'm building
is going towards
increasing energy.
And we believe
that supersymmetry
will come right beyond
there, just beyond
or at the reach of
current accelerators.
Searching for
supersymmetry was actually
one of the primary reasons
the Large Hadron Collider,
this big circular ring
in Geneva was built.
The next idea
beyond supersymmetry
is what we call Grand
Unified Theories, where
the forces would, at very
high energies, unify into one.
And at first glance,
it might seem
that such a
unification of forces
couldn't possibly
happen, because the three
fundamental forces had
different strengths.
But it turns out that
for various reasons,
as you go upwards in energy,
the strong forces become weaker.
The weak forces become stronger.
And they actually do unify.
It's rather remarkable.
So this number, 10 to
the 16 of those GeVs,
gigaelectron-volts, this
would be the natural energy
scale for grand unification.
Finally, at the very
highest energy scales,
physicists think the world
is governed by string theory.
Now, what's string theory?
This is a complicated subject.
I can barely tell you.
But let me give you a
cartoon, which I think
captures the essence.
The basic idea is
that if you looked
at an elementary particle,
like an electron,
under some really
powerful microscope,
you would find that what
it really consists of
is a vibrating loop of
energy, not a point-particle,
but a loop.
It would have structure.
And all particles
and forces in nature
would then be
unified, because they
would be different excitations
of that fundamental loop.
And higher and higher
vibrational modes
would correspond to the quarks
or the leptons or the forces
that we know or even gravity.
So therefore,
everything would be
unified as different excitations
of one fundamental entity,
which is the string.
So string theory sits at
the highest possible energy
scale you can consider.
And it's the hope that
string theory would then
provide theoretical
guidance concerning
the many possible extensions
to the standard model that
would fill this desert, as we
move upwards in energy scale
from what's down there
on the left, where
current accelerators
can reach, and what's
up here on the right, which
are the fundamental scales
of physics.
This desert is mysterious to
us, and maybe string theory
could give us some
information about that.
So this was the picture that
we carried in our heads,
certainly until the 1990s.
When I went to grad
school, this is where
I would have ended a talk.
But in the last 20
years, again, we've
had to do some rethinking.
So let me conclude this
talk by telling you
the four things that
have changed this picture
and what we now think
the new picture is.
So the first big result,
in the late '90s,
were those neutrinos.
It turned out, when I
went to grad school,
we were told that
neutrinos were massless.
No more.
We now know they have
very, very tiny masses.
Thus, it turns out,
neutrinos can do something
no other particle can do.
They can change their
identities as they
fly through space,
without interacting
with any other particle.
And remember I told you there
were three kinds of neutrinos?
An electron neutrino
can be flying along,
and it says, hey, I'd like
to be a muon neutrino now.
Oh, I want to change to tau.
Oh, I want to be an
electron neutrino again.
And they can oscillate
like this through space.
That's weird.
No other particle can do that.
Another big
discovery, of course,
was the discovery
of the Higgs boson.
For the first time, this allows
us to study important phase
transitions in the
standard model,
like water melting into ice.
There are other kinds
of phase transitions
in the standard model.
And this enables us to
probe for the first time
the underlying ground state.
Now, those are two things that
were about the standard model.
But it turns out, even
more mysteriously,
that over the past
two decades, we've
learned that the standard
model itself does not
describe the entire
reality of the universe.
Even more exists out there.
In particular, there's been
a dawning realization--
it was not a sharp discovery,
but a dawning realization,
with more and more evidence
accumulating, that there is
something called dark matter.
Now, first of all, I want
to emphasize right away,
dark matter is a bad
name, because it's not
really dark, like a black
hole sucking in all light,
but rather transparent,
in the sense
that everything we know
moves through it invisibly.
We know it's there, because
we can feel it gravitationally
through its
gravitational effects
on other objects
in the universe.
But we have no idea
what it's made of.
We don't even know if
it interacts with itself
or whether it goes through
itself transparently.
We don't even know that.
It's a complete mystery.
Yet, it turns out that this
dark matter, whatever it is,
is almost 26% of the entire
energy of the universe.
Here, I've shown what's
called the Bullet Cluster.
The red regions are regions that
are high in ordinary matter,
very dense ordinary matter.
The blue regions-- and we've
just colored them blue,
because dark matter
is transparent.
But by gravitational
sensing, we know
that this is where we
believe the dark matter is.
And you see it sits there
right alongside but separated
from ordinary matter.
It's a real object.
OK.
The other most
incredible discovery--
this happened in 1998, and
this was a complete surprise--
is that unlike dark
matter, there's something
called dark energy.
Unlike dark matter, this
permeates all of space
and acts like an
antigravity, in the sense
that it causes space itself to
expand more and more rapidly.
Because of the dark
energy, it's now
believed that the universe
will expand forever,
with an ever increasing
speed, faster and faster,
rather than approach
a stable final size
or shrink back down
into a final crunch.
We didn't know what the
universe might do eventually.
But now, because of this dark
energy, we think we know.
But what physics makes
up this dark energy?
We have no idea whatsoever.
Your guess is as good as mine.
Even worse, the dark
energy comprises--
a little bit?
No.
70% of the total
energy of the universe.
So the final big picture
I want to leave you with
is this pie chart.
We call this the cosmic pie.
This is the total energy
distribution of the universe.
That yellow slice
is normal matter.
That's the standard
model I told you about.
That's everything
we know, planets,
stars, the entire visible
universe, you, me, Tucson.
We all reside in
that little slice.
The dark matter is
that purple 26%.
It's not in the standard model.
It's currently a
complete mystery.
And then dark energy,
we have no idea at all.
And that's 69%.
Boy, this is a
rethinking if ever there
was one, when we thought
that 5% was everything.
So I hate to do this
to you, but what
that means is that this talk
ends only with mysteries.
And that's the
nature of science.
Answering one set of
questions only poses more.
But these are really
exciting times
to be a physicist, as you'll see
from the subsequent lectures,
because we're all constantly
rethinking the rules of reality
and probing the most fundamental
questions about the composition
of the universe and
the laws that it obeys.
So I urge you to stay tuned
to scientific developments
as they occur.
And most importantly, I'd
like to see you at next
week's lecture, when my
colleague, Feryal Özel,
will take you to the extreme
limits of our physical
universe.
So thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]